there seems to be an age-old question
that millions of people are googling
every single day and I'm here today to
finally help you make a decision what's
going on guys
my name is David Tomich welcome back to
the channel today we're gonna be
comparing Revit against ArchiCAD these
two programs are definitely the industry
leaders in BIM management works if
you're in the architecture profession if
you're an engineer if you're anybody in
the construction industry you've
definitely heard about these two
programs personally I've used them both
I've learnt them from start to finish
and I have a very good understanding of
what each of them can do on a day to day
basis I now use ArchiCAD for my job
because that is the program we use in my
office I guess that gives me enough of
an opinion and enough knowledge about
these two programs to truly educate you
in which one is best for what you might
need it for so if you're looking at
using Revit or ArchiCAD the first thing
that comes to mind is price for example
Revit gives you their price straight
away on their website at 3,140
Australian dollars every single year per
user that is a very high price tag to
pay for a 3d modelling program but when
it's one of the best they have a reason
to justify it if you want everything in
Revit suite which includes all their
engineering platforms and all their
vehicle movement paths and everything
I'm going to go through later in this
video that bumps it up to almost 4,200
Australian dollars archicad on the other
hand isn't as user-friendly and doesn't
give you their prices upfront as an
ArchiCAD user i know how much it costs
and it is just a little bit less than
Revit if you're looking at starting up
an ArchiCAD license getting started
installing a new platform it's probably
going to cost you a little bit more but
though they have introduced a new
payment method which might differ from
my experience but currently a one-year
membership for ArchiCAD is 2400
Australian dollars with no plugins this
is the catch
ArchiCAD requires a couple plugins and
it's definitely
Kong that we're gonna speak about soon
so let's start off by talking about
conceptual design conceptual design is
where we kind of idealize and understand
the project we take a look at it from a
3d massing point of view it could be
anything from a simple square to a
parametric object in Revit Revit allows
you to genuinely and freely express your
ideas in any way shape or form it has so
many internal built in engines and so
many plugins to get you creative you can
go from a simple square box to a full 3d
parametric skyscraper that you'd see in
Dubai within a couple of minutes
archicad on the other hand is a little
bit more basic archicad gives you the
sketchup field blocking and stacking
pull and push to really give you a
user-friendly easy experience of
blocking and stacking and conceptual
design archicad is recently in our code
23 gotten a grasshopper and rhino
plug-in so if you have done parametric
design in the past or looking to do
parametric design
now then ArchiCAD has finally caught up
to the game you're able to implement
your grasshopper or rhino plugin into
ArchiCAD and truly do some parametric
design if you have no idea what Rhino
and grasshopper are and what parametric
design is disregard it because you
probably don't need it
parametric design is a very specific
niche of architecture it's predominantly
used for freeform organic high-rises and
things that cost millions if not
billions of dollars we're talking the
skyscrapers in Dubai in Abu Dhabi and
those sorts of towers the freeform
curving and twisting unique shapes that
you don't usually get straight out of
locks the benefit of parametric design
is that you can simply and easily adjust
and fine-tune the whole building in one
simple command by coding it out instead
of manually going through shifting floor
plate by floor paper floor paid to get a
unique curve or angle that you might
like but that's a whole nother ball park
which we can definitely talk about later
if it's something to interest you guys
leave a comment down below and let me
know documenting and building can take
anywhere from a week to a couple of
years depending on the size of the
project so that means these files can
get
big very very quickly your hardware
implementations are very important I
will talk about that in the next stage
of this video but for documentation
purposes alone Revit and ArchiCAD do
very similar things and produce very
similar end results if you know how to
use the program
you will be able to document 99% of
projects in both however if you're
moving to a BIM platform like ArchiCAD
or ever you're more than likely moving
it for simple integration between your
consultants if you're a student and you
aren't thinking about consultants yet
probably start because it's a very very
important part of your career
consultants of people like structural
and civil engineers their information
can critically change the design of your
building if you aren't careful if you
aren't really paying attention to their
detail and what they're documenting
there can be lots of mistakes on site so
that's the reason BIM was actually
created to implement one model for
everybody to use and to simply integrate
it properly so that when we're designing
on a computer we can get it right there
and then and on site there's no real
errors in reality there's less errors
where that does things very differently
to how ArchiCAD does them in BIM
management record for example is an
all-in-one platform where most engineers
or highly competent large-scale
engineers are already on Revit they're
using Revit the same way you are and you
can very quickly and very easily
implement your models and send them
between each other so you aren't missing
any major information if a giant column
comes right through the middle of your
showroom and you haven't picked it up on
their 2d floor plan that's gonna be a
big problem but if you implement their
software straight into your model then
it's very easy to spot that giant column
in the middle of your showroom that's
the advantage of rabbet most engineers
are already on record so civil
structural plumbing electrical most of
these guys are documenting on Revit so
there is C files can very simply and
very easily be integrated with you
that's also one of the limitations of
Revit it doesn't have the freeform
of talking with every single program
like ArchiCAD does ArchiCAD does this in
a very different manner it does it
through an open BIM management software
so it's a process of exporting IFC files
converting them and importing them
directly into your document it's a very
similar process to what Revit does but
it can do it with many other programs
that Revit can't at the moment the
chances of your engineers and
consultants being on a different program
besides our CAD in Revit are pretty slim
if they're using 3d modeling if they're
using 2d modeling well then this
information is kind of useless to you
anyway you're going back to the typical
2d drawings and checking through every
single bit piece when it comes to
plugins and additional information that
you might need Revit has a lot more in
its general database that you can get
going and start works with straight away
whereas with ArchiCAD you're more than
likely going to have to pay for
additional plugins to get some of those
very key features that are already on
Revit an example is something that we
use in our day-to-day office and that's
cat image and 4d library the basic
library in ArchiCAD is pretty sad there
isn't that much in it whereas for des
library is an additional expense every
single year but it gives you a lot more
data to play with better doors better
windows better furniture in general and
key notes and roof coverings for example
really let you document your projects in
great detail and consistently
between different architects and drafts
people if you're looking to cost out
your project
both of these have different plugins
again they're both paid plugins they
take a lot of time and a lot of effort
to set up properly if you want to go in
and find out how much this design is
going to cost before you go out and
tender it to a builder then yes you can
definitely do it in both of these
platforms but neither one is going to
give you the magic formula where you can
just go how much is this going to cost
then it will spit out 4 million dollars
or something like that you are gonna
have to invest a lot of time and you're
gonna have to have this prior knowledge
to actually set this software up in my
opinion Revit is
very very good documenting tool but
because it has all of the engineers and
all of the consultants the sweet paths
the vehicle movements all of this in
built into the software it takes a lot
longer to learn Revit from the get-go
and if you're looking at doing
residential design or very simple design
then Revit is gonna take you longer to
learn but you're also going to be able
to do everything up to commercial design
whereas ArchiCAD you can learn that a
lot quicker I'm not kidding you
Revit is so in built and ingrained into
its precise methodology of how you need
to use it whereas arc adds a little bit
more forgiving so you can learn it in a
fraction maybe a third half the time it
would take you to learn Revit and by the
time you've learnt the skills to
actually design and document a
residential house you've already learned
the basic skills to design and document
a commercial project
you obviously need the knowledge and
know-how to do the commercial project
but that's all other things so in my
opinion if you're learning residential
small to medium scale commercial
projects and don't have a clue about
either of these ArchiCAD you'll learn it
a lot quicker Revit you'll learn it but
it will take you a lot longer and you're
going to get confused along the way
there's no doubt about it
the next category is visualization and
visualization is very important because
it's what sells your project to the
client or to the investor if you don't
have good imagery good movies then
you're gonna look a little bit average
the competition is very firm and very
hard at the moment people producing
photorealistic renders from the day one
so if you can't produce something half
decent from your software you need to
step up your game basically both of
these software's have inbuilt
3d rendering engines and both of them
are there ok they get the job done and
they're relatively quick Revit has the
advantage here of having a cloud-based
rendering software so with both of these
programs if you're rendering on your
computer it takes away the ability to
use your computer for a pretty
mount of time if you're rendering a high
quality image whereas rabbits advantage
is the fact that you can push it to the
cloud and it's done in a couple of
minutes whilst you continue to work
however that isn't the main principle
here 3d visualization if you want it to
be good is an external program and it's
definitely in an external plug-in but of
them have millions that you can look at
Revit has millions in more because it's
been designed in such a way I guess and
coded in such a way that people are
easily transitioned and pushed to this
program it's also in very high demand so
more people are creating programs
forever having said that at the moment
the best three in my opinion are
probably v-ray 3dsmax
and enscape for Revit these three take a
little bit of time to learn and scape
probably not as much as a very user
friendly but 3ds Max and v-ray are two
programs that you have to dive into
spend a few weeks to really understand
them and be able to produce some
photorealistic images at the end of that
you will get some amazing results if you
put in the time but it's another program
to learn whereas ArchiCAD has just
bought the rights to twin motion and
Unreal Engine if you're a gamer or know
anything about games you know that some
of the best and most photorealistic
games ever produced a produced through
Unreal Engine it is phenomenal what this
program can do if you have the know-how
and the skill to do it we're twin motion
comes into the play is the fact that
twin motion uses Unreal Engine software
and their knowledge and creates it into
a very user friendly easy to understand
program and something you can pick up in
seconds twin motion can produce near
photorealistic imagery instantly live
between the two software so you can have
both up at the same time editing live
changing things changing materials
textures doors windows whatever you need
to create the perfect image or video it
is slowly getting better and with the
new
20 version of twin motion and the new 20
over 20 version of Unreal Engine we're
starting to see v-ray introduced into
Unreal Engine and the promise is it'll
become available in twin the motion as
well so at the current time ArchiCAD is
probably a little bit behind of what our
Evitts plugins can do but I think that
in the next year or two
archicad's inbuilt twin motion and
Unreal Engine is going to far surpass
what Revit can do in the same amount of
time ArchiCAD also has the added benefit
of the app called BMX now BMX is a very
simple and user-friendly app that you
can download on your iPad your
smartphone any smart device and it
basically implements a 3d model into
your iPad that you can move twist cut
sections look at elevations and you can
pass this information on to your clients
most people will definitely be impressed
by this 3d software it means their whole
house is modeled in 3d they can zoom and
fly through every little nook and cranny
and they really get excited about it
whereas Revit does not have that
capability at the current time to my
knowledge so what are the pros and cons
here let's start with Revit Revit is in
extreme demand in the industry and more
and more firms are taking up Revit
you're gonna need a no effort to get
into most of the larger firms most of
the engineers are probably going to be
on Revit so you're gonna have the
ability to document that little bit
better against that you can however
there are some cons as well to Revit for
example once your files get too big and
you start to try and share them with
masses and masses of people the file
becomes unstable pretty quickly and
crashes quite often it also isn't
multi-thread compatible so you're gonna
need a very fast CPU and a dedicated
custom-built PC to run this program with
very large files effectively you're
probably not going to be able to get
away with your off-the-shelf HP computer
that has a
and nothing inside it you're gonna need
at least 16 gigs around a very good CPU
very good GPU to run most of the
projects you need and the other downside
is it is Windows only compatible if you
want to run it on a Mac you're gonna
have to run parallel so what about
ArchiCAD ArchiCAD has some great pros
first of all it's available on Mac and
Windows so you can use it on any
platform and jump between them in your
office if you need to you have the added
benefit of BIM X for free and twin
motion and Unreal Engine playing
catch-up that's a pro slash con for sure
in my personal opinion it has a better
UI and a much easier and faster learning
curve unfortunately though there isn't
as many plugins for archicad and as i've
said before it's starting to play catch
up against Revit now it's catching up
and I think it was surpass it very soon
because it used to be the opposite about
ten years ago where ArchiCAD was the
dominant one and Revit was playing
catch-up but now they seem to be
swapping courses with this new
visualization and the implementations
that they're putting in even though it
is cheaper it does cost you a little bit
more when you end up purchasing or the
additional add-ons Revit already has
these add-ons built in but unfortunately
playing catch-up again you have to pay
for more add-ons what's the conclusion
if you're a student I think it's very
important that you learn both of these
programs students need to be able to
really get into any firm when they
graduate because you can't just walk
into the firm you want go hello boss I
want a job you're gonna have to apply it
and be very competitive which means
you're probably gonna get rejected from
the firm you really want to go to and
you're gonna have to have your second or
third pick in other cases you might have
your tenth pick but that doesn't matter
it's knowing and being able to
understand both programs to give
yourself the best chance at getting into
both firms if you're already in the
industry stick to what you know it's
very simple firms use the program that
you use you're never going to change
that if you know ArchiCAD you're not
going to walk into a firm that uses
Revit and can
from all to learn ArchiCAD you're the
one that's gonna have to learn Revit if
you're already on Revit and you're doing
Revit very well in your firm what's the
point of changing it's going to take
years to build new templates and really
get up the speed you were on the
previous program for some simple
features that might not save you that
much time in the future it's really
weighing up those pros and cons there
and I guess if you were only to pick one
it depends what kind of architect you
want to be what kind of designer you
want to be if you want to design
residential and only residential I don't
think you need to overcomplicate it
by learning Revit I think ArchiCAD is
perfect it's cheaper and it's fast it
alone I think if you're even going up to
five six ten story apartment buildings
ArchiCAD is still perfect it's powerful
enough it's quick enough and it's easy
enough to be able to document something
of this sort when you move into those
high-rises and I'm talking 50 60 stories
Abu Dhabi is to buy a level quality and
you're a multi-billion dollar firm
you're probably gonna name that Revit
because it has the ability to do this
parametric design and to implement with
all your engineers when it's that size
you need to make sure every detail is
right and if you're looking to visualize
well realistically neither of them has
great visualization you're going to need
to learn a third separate program to be
able to produce the best imagery so pick
what you think is gonna work best for
you as a designer as an architect and go
from there they both have the ability to
produce photorealistic versions just how
you do it is completely up to you
alright that's all for me today guys I
think that was a very long rant but I
hope you enjoyed it I hope I gave you
some clarity around Revit and ArchiCAD
and which one you should pick for your
specific design goals if you enjoyed the
video make sure you smash that subscribe
button
20:20 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday